[Music]
what's happened to the villain at the
end of doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness and what's up with that
post-credits sequence these are the
confusing moments in dr strange 2
explained
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness opens with america chavez and
the variant of doctor strange running
from a fiery beast in a mysterious
location it's an action-packed way to
start the movie off and as a result it
can be a bit difficult your first time
through to fully grasp what's going on
with the information revealed later in
the film however the film's opening
starts to make a lot more sense
presumably america encountered this
ponytailed version of doctor strange
during her journey through the
multiverse which she initially undertook
in search of her missing parents at some
point around the time of her meeting him
america starts being pursued by various
monsters she and strange manage to
figure out that they're trying to take
her powers but they don't quite solve
the mystery of who's behind the attacks
it's only revealed later that wonder
maxum offers the one pulling the strings
as she needs america's universe hopping
powers to find her children once again
how exactly wonder is able to reach
across dimensions so summoned beasts of
such immense power isn't directly
explained but given how powerful she's
shown to be with a darkhold guiding her
chaos magic it's not too much of a
stretch to guess of course in the end
the scarlet witch quits with the
monsters and decides to do the job
herself
for any mcu fans who missed one division
on disney plus scarlet witch's
transition from avengers to murderous
villain might seem a bit abrupt even for
those who did see the miniseries her
turn to the dark side is far more severe
than anything glimpsed previously in
multiverse of madness wonders evil
ambitions are revealed when she's asked
by doctor strange to help america little
does he know that she's the one
endangering the poor girl in the first
place i made mistakes
and people were hurt
essentially wonder's obsessive use of
the darkhold since the end of one
division has poisoned her grief over
time and turned it into a violent need
for control at any cost the film later
reveals that her personality has
practically been split in two between
her original self and her corrupted
scarlet witch persona it might seem like
a bit of a jump but that's just the
power of the dark hold on display
that's the book of the damned
there are some other interesting things
about this particular scene however for
instance wonder creates an entire
elaborate illusion of a thriving orchard
to fall strange into thinking she's left
her magic behind her he only notices the
deception when she says america's name
which she should have no way of knowing
it's a baffling slip up for such a
powerful and cunning character and it
raises the question was the mistake and
instance of the real wonder's
personality shining through
after arriving on earth 838 dr strange
and america travers encounter a scanner
that recalls and displays important
memories steven's memory scan involves
his relationship with christine palmer
and america's shows a tragic moment from
her childhood the first time her portal
opening powers manifested accidentally
rocketing her mothers into an unknown
dimension in the film the memory is
mostly used to build a bit more of an
emotional foundation for america
establishing both her grief and her
drive to find her parents however the
context surrounding her upbringing isn't
really touched on in the comics america
is born in a dimension called the
utopian parallel a world that exists
beyond the reaches of the multiverse and
the regular time stream drawing a
potential cataclysm that had nothing to
do with america herself her moms made a
noble sacrifice to help protect their
home obviously the mcu is already
diverging from that version of the story
in some big ways but from what's glimpse
of america's old home in the movie it
seems like a lot about her origin may be
the same the utopian parallels existence
outside the multiverse could explain why
america doesn't dream or have any other
variants even more interesting is the
fact that in the comics the utopian
parallel is sustained by the power of
the demiurge an all-powerful being who
happens to be the final form of wonder
maximoff's son billy aka wiccan it seems
that america's connection to the scarlet
witch could be just beginning
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness spends a lot of time on earth
838 a reality in which the planet is
secretly guided by the powerful
illuminati and thanos was defeated with
the mystical book of vashanti there are
a lot of little details on easter eggs
sprinkled throughout the alternate
dimension that are easy to miss but they
provide a lot of important context to
the state of that particular universe
while 838 isn't a major designation in
the marvel comics multiverse the world
scene in multiverse of madness pulls a
lot of details from previously inked
storylines for instance when christine
palmer tells stephen and america that
she works for the baxter foundation it's
an immediate clue that the fantastic
four exists in her universe the baxter
building has long been the headquarters
of the iconic marvel superhero team and
in the 2015 fox film adaptation the
baxter foundation is a research group
that reed richards sue storm and the
rest of the group work for it seems
unlikely that any major details from
that particular movie will be brought
into the mcu but the similarity is still
worth noting
say that again
given that black bolts and professor
charles xavier are also present on earth
838 it stands to reason that mutants and
the inhumans are both present there in
many ways these details make earth838
feel closer to the earth 616 of the
comics than the main 616 universe of the
mcu
arguably the most exciting part of dr
strange and the multiverse of madness is
the introduction of the illuminati to
the mcu simply having a group by that
name in the franchise is a big deal as
the illuminati are important players in
a number of major comic book story lines
even more intriguing are the specific
members of earth 838 illuminati each of
whom has a unique point of origin baron
mordo seems to be a relatively simple
variant of the character we saw in the
first doctor strange but the rest of the
team have more complicated backgrounds
captain carter is an alternate version
of captain america first glimpse in the
mcu in marvel's what if season 1. in
that story peggy carter ends up taking
the super soldier serum instead of steve
rogers due to complications during the
procedure anson mount returns as the
inhuman black bolts though he seems to
be a different version than the one we
last saw in the short-lived abc inhumans
show the h38 version of captain marvel
isn't carol danvers but rather her 616
wingmate maria rambo patrick stewart
reprises his role as professor rex from
the non-mcu x-men movies but his golden
chair and presentation are closer to the
version seen in x-men the animated
series we should tell him the truth
last on the list is john krasinski's mr
fantastic who while not part of the
franchise previously has been a popular
fan cast for years the whole group also
employs a version of ultron that seems
markedly less sinister than the one from
earth 616 as a whole the illuminati and
multiverse of madness serve largely the
same purpose as their equivalent team in
the comics guiding the world in secret
toward a future that they deem to be
optimal
after her original copy of the dark hole
is destroyed wander forces wong to take
her to mount wondergore the source of
the ancient text wang briefly explains
that the mountain was once inhabited by
a demon called kathan who carved his
dark spells into the rock when wonder
arrives she finds what seems to be a
shrine erected to the scarlet witch and
a group of cthulhu-esque monsters who
bow at her feet in the comics cathon is
an elder god one of the oldest and most
powerful beings in earth's history
catholic eventually departs earth for a
parallel dimension but before he goes he
inscribes all the dark chaos magic he
knows within the walls of mount
wondergore as an infant in the comics
wonder maximoff is experimented on
within the bounds of the mountain
connecting her to c'thun's dark power
it's still a bit unclear what percentage
of wonder's power in the mcu is due to
her exposure to the mine stone and how
much was latent magical ability until
more of the scarlet witch prophecy is
revealed it's hard to say for sure
when scarlet witch dreamwalks into earth
838 reality in pursuit of america chavez
she quickly begins ripping a bloody path
through everyone who stands in her way
her body count includes the full roster
of the illuminati each of whom dies in
brutal fashion the first to fall in the
battle is black bolt who also arguably
suffers the most grotesque fate
in trying to talk wonder down mr
fantastic tells her that black balls
could kill her with a single word from
his powerful voice in response wonder
seals the hero's mouth completely shut
causing him to panic overcome with
terror at having his mouth glued shirt
he can't contain his fear and appears to
scream in horror because that scream has
nowhere to go it ends up blowing his own
brains out from the inside scarlet
witch's kills on the other illuminati
members are similarly gruesome she
slices captain carter in half with her
own shield shreds mr fantastic salasic
body into pieces and fights back against
professor x's psychic invasion well
enough to kill him from within his own
mind
the illuminati's last attempt at
stopping wonder comes in the form of
charles xavier whose formidable
telepathic abilities allow him to enter
her mind in search of a way to end her
rampage in her mind he finds a white
void occupied by small piles of urban
rubble in a clear call back to the
childhood memories we see in one
division beneath one of these piles
xavier finds a trapped wonder it's not
made clear exactly who this wonder is
she could be the character's original
heroic persona that's been locked away
by the darkhold's corruptive magic or
the psyche of earth a3a's wonder or
something else entirely charles tries to
free her from her prison but before he
can finish the job the scarlet witch's
own mental powers find him and
extinguish his life for good how exactly
one that kills charles is a bit unclear
her powers aren't explicitly psychic in
nature but it's feasible that her chaos
magic could manifest in more cognitive
ways fans of the x-men movies may get
some flashbacks to the dark phoenix
storyline which also revolves around a
red hued hero who falls to the dark side
due to a powerful alternate persona
xavier's attempts to save wonder and his
subsequent death mirror the events of
x-men at the last stand and it's
doubtful that's a coincidence on the
part of marvel studios
as scarlet witch hunts america chavez
and doctor strange they hunt for the
book of vishanti an ancient tome of pure
good magic that stands in opposition to
the evil of the dark hold america nearly
claims a book in the opening sequence of
the movie but she's forced to bail out
into earth 616 instead later on she
stephen and a variant of christine
palmer end up finding the book of
vashanti but just as they're about to
tap into its power scarlet witch
destroys it for something that's said to
be so immensely important the book of
vashanti certainly doesn't get to do
much in doctor strange too in the comics
the tome is crafted by three deities
called the vashanti one of whom is
agamotto the same figure who forges dr
strange's eye of agamotto not all of
that lore has been officially canonized
in the mcu but a few things about the
film version of the book are made clear
first and foremost it's implied that
there's only one book of vashanti as
christine claims that the dimension
where they find it is the sort of nexus
point between other parts of the
multiverse that would make the book
fundamentally different from the
darkhold which has numerous copies
across dimensions
after scarlet witch seemingly destroys
the book of vashanti doctor strange and
christine fall through one of america's
portals into a post-apocalyptic
wasteland they deduce that the realm
they've entered is a result of an
incursion the cataclysmic collision of
multiple universes and the only survivor
they managed to find is another variant
of strange himself this new sorcerer
proves to be quite sinister however
leading to a magical showdown between
the two doppelgangers the sequence could
feel a bit confusing because it
admittedly employs a lot of awfully
convenient coincidences how did that
version of the darkhold happen to be
possessed by another doctor strange how
did they manage to find that strange so
quickly and easily and what's
essentially an empty void the film
doesn't really provide satisfying
answers to these questions preferring
more of a deus ex machina approach
though the evil doctor strange and
multiverse of madness is a different
variant he shares some similarities with
the one scene in marvel's what-if season
1. in that story a version of the doctor
becomes obsessed with saving christine's
life ultimately leading him to destroy
his entire universe knowledge of the
what-if episode sheds a bit of light on
the events of multiverse of madness as
it shows how most versions of the
character can easily fall down dark
holes of an healthy fixation
after defeating his evil doppelganger
stephen takes his evil twin's copy of
the darkhold and uses it to dreamwalk
back into his home dimension using the
corpse of the doctor strange variant
brought there with america chavez at the
beginning of the film the doctor
explains that dreamwalking allows a
caster to inhabit a dead body but such a
desperate move comes with its own unique
set of consequences condemnation by the
souls of the damned as soon as strange
begins manipulating his zombified form
an army of ghouls appear and tried to
drag him well somewhere presumably the
dead rise to confront strange because
he's essentially practicing necromancy
scarlet witch receives no such visit
from the damned when she dreamwalks into
a living variant of herself so it stands
to reason that the ghosts are only
bothered by someone spitting in death's
eye things get a bit more complicated
however when christine urges stephen to
use his mystical powers to control the
souls of the damned which he does
whether this is an ability that's always
been accessible to him or something made
possible by the darkhold is left unclear
most likely it's a combination of the
two something that only a powerful
sorcerer could achieve through the use
of dark magic
from start to finish of dr strange in
the multiverse of madness wanda maximoff
lives up to her potential as one of the
most powerful beings in the entire mcu
she lays ways to carmitage uses the
sorcerer's own containment spells
against them spreads her consciousness
across multiple realities and calls an
army of monsters and demons to do her
bidding in the end the only one strong
enough to defeat the scarlet witch is
wonder herself your power exceeds that
of the sorcerer supreme
america punches wonder through a portal
back to earth 838 where she comes face
to face with the variant she previously
possessed and her two children tommy and
billy seeing the looks of terror on her
son's faces breaks something within
wonder stopping her bloody rampage dead
in its tracks she then returns to earth
616 and proceeds to bring down the
entirety of mount wondergore varying the
ancient dark magic within and destroying
every universe's version of the darkhold
wonders about face happens pretty
quickly but it makes sense given what's
established earlier in the film it's
made clear when charles xavier enters
her mind that the scarlet witch persona
has basically imprisoned wonder within
her own mind presumably the sight of her
terrified children is enough to break
wander free because the scarlet witch
persona might quickly be able to regain
power wonder wastes no time in seemingly
destroying herself and the darkhold
after defeating wonder saving the world
and returning home doctor strange tries
to get back to something resembling a
normal life that plan is offended
however in the final scene before the
first round of credits in which doctor
strange collapses in the middle of the
street the last shot shows a third eye
open in his forehead mirroring the one
worn by his sinister doppelganger
earlier in the film considering that
strange's evil variant has his own third
eye as a result of using the darkhold it
seems that our heroic strange might have
been corrupted during his use as well
open your eye
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness has a brief but significant
post-credits scene while walking down
the street strange is accosted by a
purple clad woman played by charlize
theron who claims that he's responsible
for causing a multiversal incursion she
demands that he comes with her to fix it
and he readily agrees opening his third
eye and following her through a portal
that she slashes open with a mystical
blade the credits identify theron's
character as clear a name that fans of
the comics will instantly recognize in
the original marvel stories clear is a
resident of the dark dimension who
fights a constant battle against the
evil of dumamu who is also her uncle
because the ancient being is also one of
dr strange's primary foes he and clear
become allies they even get married
later on in the comics though their
union eventually meets a tragic end
if clear and stephen's mcu relationship
is at all like it is in the comics the
doctor has some big things coming his
way
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you